coût est devenu apparent l'hôtel hilton
cissé melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine j'ai une question qui est
souvent agressé par plusieurs personnes
dont je vais de répondre un peu
aujourd'hui c'est à quand la véritable
réconciliation
la véritable réconciliation faudrait
probablement décider quelles sont
vraiment les signes d'une réconciliation
est ce que c'est le fait d'avoir accès à
sa langue de la même manière que le
français et l'anglais sont accessibles
est ce que ça veut dire des services de
santé qui sont culturellement
sécuritaire est ce que ça veut dire de
sentir en sécurité justement quand on va
adresser nos problématiques à des agents
de police est ce que ça veut dire une
présence vraiment représentative dans
les niveaux des états avec des
représentants des représentants
autochtones qui sont pas nécessairement
du gouvernement provincial fédéral
municipal mais qui sont là pour les
questions autochtones donc la
réconciliation c'est dans le fond de
réparer ce qui a été endommagé depuis
500 ans faut pas oublier que le canada
était bâtie sur une relation dite
d'entente et et de traiter avec les
premières nations mais tout ce qui a été
fait après n'a pas tendu à prouver que
justement cette entente le respect l'un
était instaurée et les pensionnats et
l'arer les années 60 ont juste rajouter
une couche de blessures sur toute cette
injustice qui avait été mis en place
donc la véritable réconciliation avec
l'ong atteindre parce que ça va demander
beaucoup d'argent de temps d'éducation
de patience aussi parce qu'on parle de
deux nations qui ont été blessées les
unes envers les autres pour pouvoir
atteindre un équilibre qui fait que
finalement les premières nations ont le
droit et ont même
la main le même niveau de respect que
n'importe quel autre citoyen canadien ou
québécois
cependant avec des droits qui sont
différentes puisque nous étions ici
depuis plus de sept mille ans on a des
droits qui sont reconnus à
l'international même comme étant les
premiers peuples fondateurs du pays
ça risque de demander énormément mais ce
qui est vraiment rassurant c'est que je
vois un désir d'atteindre cette
réconciliation là je vois aussi une
progression par rapport aux relations
que les gens ont avec les premières
nations qui est très différente de celle
que je voyais quand j'avais 10 12 ans
par exemple
à quand la réconciliation ça va être
l'énergie et le temps qu'on voyait m et
plus on en est et plus ça va arriver
rapidement
je pense qu on est beaucoup plus proche
de l'atteindre que de s'en éloigner
donc merci beaucoup quand vous nous
posez cette question là c'est que vous
avez à coeur justement cette
réconciliation là et ça veut dire que le
travail qu'on fait ici à l'espace
autochtone n'est pas perdu et tend vers
cette réconciliation là alors je
souhaite une belle semaine et j'espère
que vous y serez pas partager les vidéos
et à nous envoyer des questions